-Our next guest is
the United States Secretar
of the Interior.
Please welcome to the show
Secretary Deb Haaland.
Thank you so much
for being here, Secretary.
-It's my pleasure.
Thanks for having me, Seth
-This may or may not
surprise you --
you are the first secretar
of the Interior
we have ever had on the show
[ Laughter ]
-Well, some reason,
I believe that.
Thanks for having me.
-Now, I think that people
don't quite understand
what an expansive portfoli
this job has.
I certainly didn't.
What would you tell people
who are watching,
and may be as uneducated
as I am about the job,
what it is that you guys do,
day in and day out?
-Well, we manage millions
of acres
of public lands,
waters, natural resources
for the benefit
of the American people.
We conserve those resources,
so that future generations
will have them.
And we honor the trust
and treaty obligations
of Indian tribes.
-You mentioned Indian tribes
You were, sort of famously
and maybe a little bit lately,
for our nation's history,
but you were the first
Native American secretary
in our United States Cabinet
And was that something
that you were able to proces
in the moment,
the historical significanc
of that?
-Well, Seth, considering
the fact that I was sworn in
by the very first
woman vice president,
also a woman of color,
[ Laughter ]
that was really
probably the best part.
-I'm sorry, Secretary.
I'm going to interrupt you
real quick.
You have a staffer
who fully crawled
on the carpet behind you
and it is the greatest thing
I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
Sir.
Sir, we know you're
behind the desk.
Okay.
I would love to --
Thank you very much.
Now, Secretary, be honest.
Do you know who that man is?
[ Laughter ]
And...
are those someone else's
glasses he's wearing?
-No. We don't have people
sort of sneaking around,
so, yes, I know who that i
and thank you
for making light of it, Seth
-I mean, thank you.
You know, we've had giant
comedy stars on this show
and not one of them
has thought to have somebody
crawl by in the background
[ Laughter ]
But you were talking about the
historical significance
and also, you know,
it should be noted,
you know, for a department
that has a long and,
oftentimes, violent, history
with Native Americans
in this country.
-Yes, violent, that's puttin
it mildly, I think, Seth.
I mean, you know, for centuries,
Indians were --
I mean, we're victims
of genocide, quite frankly
since the Europeans came
to this continent
and began colonizing
Native Americans
in this country.
We've been through many eras
of detrimental federal policies,
assimilation.
You know, my grandmother,
for example,
was taken from her home
when she was eight
and sent
to Catholic boarding school.
For five years,
she wasn't able to come home
So those are some of the thing
that we live with
and it's caused generational
trauma to many communities
And so I feel like,
with President Biden in office
with his priority of ensurin
that we live up
to those trust
and treaty obligations,
that it's a new era
for Indian country.
I assume,
any time a different party
takes over the White House
you obviously have a chang
in philosophies
with the department's
different Cabinet member's run
But I imagine that this is
as much of a 180
as you can imagine,
with what Donald Trump was doing
with his, you know,
Department of the Interior
versus what President Bide
is doing.
You know, Ryan Zinke,
who had your job,
had to resign,
due to an ethics scandal.
It was taken over
by an oil and gas lobbyist
The Trump administration
opened up
a lot of these public land
for oil and gas exploration.
How was the state
of the department
or how did you find it
when you came in?
-So I'll tell you, Seth,
I am so proud to be
on a team of career
professionals who have --
I mean,
we have some employees,
some career staff here
at the department,
who have worked here
for 47 years.
People have dedicated
their careers
to protecting our public lands
I'm thankful that they staye
through those years
and that they're here,
ready to work and make sur
that we are meeting
the priorities of the president,
making sure that we are goin
to preserve these lands,
conserve our lands
for future generations.
I want everyone's grandkid
to experience
what I've experienced,
you know, on mountain trails
climbing up to the top
of the Washington Monument
All of those things are here
for everyone to enjoy
and we owe it
to the career professional
right here at the DOI.
-How can your department assis
with the pro-climate agend
that the president has laid out?
-Oh, my goodness.
We can do a lot!
You know, we just announce
Vineyard Wind.
It's going to be
this tremendous wind project
off the coast of Massachusetts
It'll create 3,600 jobs.
We want to make sure
that we are --
[ Crackling nearby ]
We have a 30x30 initiative
the America the Beautiful
Initiative.
We're going to conserve 30
of our land and oceans by 2030
make sure that we're
protecting habitat.
Right now,
we're just on the edge
of celebrating
the Endangered Species Act
The bald eagle
is the highest numbers
that it's been for decades
and we absolutely, I mean,
we have a lot to celebrate
So we're going to keep
on that trajectory.
We're going to make sure
that climate change
is a priority for us here
at the DOI
and we're working in conjunction
with many of my colleagues
in other departments
to make sure that
we are doing our utmost
to turn that around.
-I want to ask --
in your role as secretary,
do you have to sign off
on the social media tweets
that the Department of the
Interior has been putting out?
-You know, Seth, I want
to give tremendous kudos
to my communications department.
It's really good
because I don't manage it.
-Well, I'm a little glad
to hear you say that
because here's some
of what you put out.
Here's a photo of some baby owls
and it says,
"Whooo let the kids out?
Whoo Whoo Whoo!"
[ Laughter ]
-Aren't they cute, though?
Aren't they just adorable?
-They are adorable,
but that's besides the point
[ Laughter ]
We have this -- What do you call
a moose with no name?"
Do you know the answer to this
-[ Laughs ]
Unfortunately, I don't.
-Anonymoose.
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
based on you laughing at this,
that means they're writing
to your sense of humor.
[ Laughter ]
And then, this one
is a photo of a caribou.
I will admit, Secretary, I had
to read this one three times
to even get it,
which, for the record,
happens all the time
with my writers here
and their jokes,
so I'm not judging.
But, "Even when you're alone
we caribou-t you."
"We caribou-t you."
-Hey, I want to give peopl
a little bit of leeway
to express themselves
[ Laughter ]
on social media.
-Well, you do that enough
and you end up with a writer
named Mike Scollins.
[ Laughter ]
That's what happened to me
And you do not
want that to happen.
Hey, I want to end
by mentioning this.
I am married
to an incredible woman
who was born
and raised in New Mexico
one of the greatest states
in the Union,
that I'd never been to,
and, now, I go to all the time
-Absolutely.
It's a "Land of Enchantment.
-And I guess my question is,
every time I go,
the only downside is I hav
to stay with my in-laws
and can I crash with you?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, you're welcome any time.
-I really appreciate that.
Secretary, it has been
a pleasure talking with you.
Keep up the great work and
hopefully, we'll see you again
-Thanks so much.
Thanks for having me.
-Your staff member,
is he still in the room?
Does he want to wave goodbye
[ Laughter ]
Does he know he's going
to be a meme?
Because maybe
you should let him know.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks so much.
-It might be better
coming from you.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, Seth.
Good to be here.
-Thank you. All the best.